but more i just say he checks the
temperature of the player across from
and he's going to see
if porzingis wants to play physical
tonight or stay out in three-point land
kelly ubre running the floor well gets
the easy bucket inside
different guys for essentially 10 games
each that's half a season
with covid so myself
beautiful finish he got around cleva
that time and he'll pick up the foul as
well
get downhill use your handle that's a
good crossover
you're getting no help everybody else is
staying home no shot blockers in right
now
for the warriors curry finds uber a the
south paw fires and hits and a good sign
for kelly ubrey those villanova guys boy
they come to the nba they just
contribute right away there's uber the
lefty
knocks this one down so kelly ubreze hit
a couple of threes here chris
on both ends not falling here last three
possessions now uber
looking for room to work a little
pull-up nice little mid-range and
toscano ants anderson gave him a little
room to work in there
warriors down two stephen curry back on
the floor
nice finish good catch it was almost
knocked away but ubra there to secure it
and score it he is
the top scorer in this game brunson has
17 on the board
goes with the right hand his off hand he
scores
and one is energy i mean listen the last
16 games
it hasn't been shooting that way
quickly back ubra set up by wiggins
three-pointer number three for kelly
uber a junior
hook draymond going in his bag tonight
and matter of fact he's still in this
assist bag
from the corner va
[Applause]
porzingis has made a couple of threes oh
look at that draymond green to kelly
ubra
saying yeah i like where you are
cazingas use that seven foot four body
to shoot it in the paint
ubrae hits another one adding to his
season high this is getting everything
he wants in the paint good defense no
it's not good defense not a hand up or
anything dallas made 15 threes in the
first half just three in the third
quarter
get their first of the fourth now here's
ubra oh what a night
he is having ubereat now 34.
look at some good games coming up what
do you think about the brooklyn nets
there chris are they
are you a believer yet let's say are
they going to be able to stop anybody
i'm going to believe in uber
the three is down so well tonight
getting his teammates involved and
knocking it down five for seven
two for four from the three-point line
12 points
there it is kelly uber now has a new
career high
deflections what a night for
kelly ubrey oh we got a shot blocked
twice
he walks it from behind with the new
type of
tumbler look at his two blocks one give
me that way to get in that multi trying
to get into here
from the weak side now show us what you
mean